die Tastatur ist sehr wahrscheinlich der
Gegenstand mit dem ich Tag für Tag am
längsten im physischen Kontakt bin
Tastaturen gibt es in allen Formen und
Größen egal ob wild Gaming mäßig mit
LEDs oder schlichtes modernes Design
oder wilde ergonomische Tastaturen von
dem anderen Planeten gefühlt es gibt
sogar Tastaturen die man aufräumen kann
die sind aber aus eigener Erfahrung
richtig schlecht fast alle sind auf
jeden Fall aus Kunststoff weniger haben
zum Teil Alu verbaut und Holz findet man
so gut wie gar nicht während der
Tastatur will die von außen komplett aus
Holz ist landet schnell auf Seiten wo
man sieben oder sogar 900 € dafür
bezahlt
das könnte man jetzt ausgeben oder man
baut sie einfach selbst und findet
schmerzhaft heraus wieso das so
aufwendig ist das ein anderer sich das
nur freiwillig antut fast 1000 € dafür
gibst dieses Video wird unterstützt von
Steuerbord mehr dazu später recherchiert
ob man sich einfach das Innenleben von
der Tastatur so extra kaufen kann hat
nichts gefunden deswegen ist es
wahrscheinlich der schlauste einfach
seine Tastatur zu nehmen und erstmal
komplett zu zerlegen und wir machen das
hoffentlich so dass man hinterher auch
wieder so zusammenbauen kann wie sie
jetzt aktuell ist also erstmal alle
Tassen runter soll jeder einzelne aus
Holz gemacht sein und zum Vorschein
kommen
die ganzen Switches heißen glaube ich
komme später dazu jetzt als erstes kommt
mal das Gehäuse weg ich bin gespannt was
da drin ist und wie so eine Tastatur von
innen aussieht
und man sieht die Tastatur ist vor allem
viel Luft weil ich fand die nämlich viel
zu dick aber eigentlich kann ja auch
viel dünner sein und ich glaube so
machen wir die auch das krass alles
unter diesem pinöpen hier ist einfach
Luft einfach unnötig viel Platz also
irgendwie müssen hier raus ich habe so
eine Befürchtung ich glaube die ist da
echt dran gelötet ne ja also wenn man
diese schwarze Plastikschicht jetzt
entfernen will geht das nur wenn man
jeden einzelnen dieser Schalter hier
ablötet ihr seht wie viele Stellen das
sind ein bisschen hobbylos aber da sind
auch wenn man richtig Interesse ich bin
los
ich habe hier so ein Gerät idealerweise
ist das von einer speziell heiß und
schmilzt den blödsinnig jetzt ist
geschmolzen jetzt richtig Knopf Pam und
der sollte die das blöds wegsaugen und
ich glaube ja und damit geht das dann
raus
geil okay ja ich freue mich jetzt weil
es ziemlich cool ist allerdings
verstehen aber so ist das letzte
[Musik]
also dafür wie viele Tasten geht das
tatsächlich ziemlich schnell
[Musik]
das ging schneller als erwartet
das kann ich hier das Gerüchte PCB Board
wegnehmen und die machen jetzt einmal
heraus
[Musik]
dann ist hier einmal das komplette
Innenleben von der Tastatur ist richtig
krass wie wenig das eigentlich ist den
wollte hier mit dem plastiktasten den
werden wir erstmal nicht mehr brauchen
ich gebe zu auf aber das machen aus Holz
noch mal komplett neu zuerst allerdings
brauchen erstmal neues Gehäuse für das
hier und das mal jetzt hier die Maße
richten sich dabei nach der Platine
exakt 37 * 12,4 mmmter 37 mal 12 12 4 5
das ist ja Holz so mache ich die
Wandstärke ein bisschen dicker ich würde
mal sagen drei Millimeter
ich will noch eine schöne Form haben
also manchmal eher acht weil dann kann
ich das Außen hier nämlich abrunden was
für ein Radius haben die Dinger wohl
hier ich habe dazu ein Werkzeug dass ich
zugegebenermaßen extrem selten benutzt
und zwar eine radienlehre eine
sogenannte und die kann man einfach
irgendwann Sachen dran halten und
schauen wie radiosmäßig die sind auf
jeden Fall mehr als 1,5 mm mit zwei das
passt halt auch noch nicht ganz ne
es ist 2,25 wer macht sowas ja ich auf
jeden Fall nicht welchen Radius hat
eigentlich die Rundung USB-Stecker ich
schätze mal zwei nee das ist viel zu
groß 1,5
[Musik]
ja und jetzt muss ich eigentlich das
Teil hier eins zu eins nachholen damit
ich den Rest von machen kann
jetzt wird das Gehäuse der Tastatur
fertig sein ist ist an der Zeit das
Modell Realität werden zu lassen dafür
haben wir primär Eichenholz ausgewählt
für unsere Pfannen greifen wir natürlich
wieder auf unsere 10c Fräse zurück als
ersten Schritt spannen wir einen kleinen
Bohrer ein bohren die Löcher für die
Schrauben und machen dann noch eine
kleine Phase dran
[Musik]
als nächstes Fräsen wir die Abdeckung
bzw das Gesicht der Tastatur in das die
Schalter der Tasten eingelassen werden
sollen weil ich dafür gern ein dunkleres
Holz hätte dass ich ein bisschen absetzt
von der Eiche wir sowas aber nicht hier
haben hat Manu einfach ein Walnuss von
ihr auf eine dünne HDF Platte geleimt
das ist so zusammengepresstes Zeug aus
Holz abbellen
also das Gehäuse haben wir jetzt hier
ziemlich geil ein bisschen uneben hier
geworden aber ist egal dass die
hinterher später eh nicht es ist alles
so rausgekommen wie das geplant war und
jetzt das einfach mal ob diese Platine
hier ob die auch so drauf passt wie
gesagt ich freue mich schon sehr wenn
die Tastatur fertig ist und ich damit
eine Runde Minecraft spielen kann was
man mit der Tastatur aber auch machen
könnte wer seine Steuererklärung mit
Steuerbord den Sponser des heutigen
Videos um sich im Schnitt 1.95 € vom
Staat zurückzuholen Steuerberater hat
nämlich nicht nur eine super praktische
und unkomplizierte App für Smartphone
sondern auch eine Website auch dort
gibt's das smarte jetlayout mit dem ihr
im Schnitt in 20 Minuten fertig seid und
direkt ans Finanzamt übermitteln kann
und da die Frist für die Einreichung
eurer Steuererklärung fürs letzte Jahr
schon am 2.10 endet solltet ihr euch
ranhalten und Steuerbord einfach mal
probieren
[Musik]
ihr habt dabei nämlich nicht so
verlieren denn wenn die Rückerstattung
weniger als 50 Euro beträgt ist
Steuerbord für euch komplett kostenlos
und erst über 50 Euro werden euch von
dem erstattet in Betrag im Schnitt 1095
Euro mit meinem Code tomory nur 29,99
abgezogen bis zu vier Jahre rückwirkend
könnte der Steuererklärung noch
einreichen also klick auf den Link in
der Videobeschreibung um steuerbar zu
bekommen und holt euch euer Geld vom
Start zurück gerne auch über diesen
QR-Code die passen super dir auch
vermessen leider bei dem auch der passt
der passt der passt auch nicht und der
auch nicht und ja die passen alle neu
machen wir jetzt dumm ich Brecht die
einmal raus und dann äh ich markiere mir
mal alle die jetzt gleich rauskicken
werde
zack oh nee
und der hat schon gepasst na gut also
wieder drauf vorsichtiger sein ne das
ist gute Lektion
der ist weg
so das waren alle drauf
[Musik]
aber ich steigert den Wert des Produkts
weil das ist Handwerk guter Fernseher
warum habe ich das eigentlich nicht
rausgenommen
ziemlich geil muss ich gerne aber
Schleifen aber zuerst fehlt hier diese
Aussparung für diesen usb-c-port hier
9,6
[Musik]
damit
mache ich das jetzt drauf
weil wenn ich da jetzt eine Computer
ansteckt
soll das Leuchten und es tut auch nice
ja ich würde sagen das sieht man
definitiv
frisch
noch ein bisschen abgeschliffen
und genau das Teil und aber auch das
Gehäuse weil der abgeschliffen werden
jetzt ein bisschen geölt damit es auch
schön aussieht
direkt viel dunkler das ist einfach
wirklich das geilste
am ganzen Holzarbeiten einfach am Ende
mit Öl einschmieren das überschüssige Öl
weg
[Musik]
wir sind beide Teile und die baue ich
jetzt mal zusammen ich hoffe die passen
wird es hier einmal so reingelegt Klick
und das passt wie angegossen das ist
krass das jetzt wirklich aber ein Ding
ein unit eine Einheit und sieht gut aus
auch von der Höhe her komplett bündig
und damit kommen auch schon unsere
Freunde wieder zum Einsatz die Switches
also einfach diese die Schalter halt
dafür muss ich das wieder abmachen war
jetzt noch mal eine Probe und wenn ich
das ja jetzt drauf legt übrigens sieht
man auch schon dass alle passen ja alle
passen richtig gut also eher
da muss leider ein bisschen vermessen
aber das dribbel ich irgendwie hin das
ist trotzdem geht und jetzt kommt z.B
der Switch hier rein und zwar genauso
rum der passt da sehr sehr knapp rein
aber gerade so genauso wie sein soll
bleiben noch ein Stück
[Musik]
kommen wir zum Punkt jetzt richtig
richtig los die kompletten 200 irgendwas
Pins müssen da jetzt angelötet werden
[Musik]
das Ergebnis Holz mit Technik fusioniert
coole Sache das Gehäuse finde ich ist
sehr sehr hübsch alle Schalter sind
jetzt drin das ist alles dicht finde ich
gut das einzige was jetzt so fehlt weil
das Tastatur würde das jetzt an sich
schon durchgehen sind natürlich noch die
Tasten die Tasten wollen wir auch als
Holz machen jetzt ist das Problem wie
kriegt man da Holz drauf man müsste
dieses kleine plus hier da irgendwie ins
Holz rein fräsen das ist aber ein
bisschen zu filigran und ein bisschen zu
komplex das so zu machen dass es auch
wirklich passt Tomaten 3D Druck Adapter
modelliert die sehen dann so aus und
passen auch perfekt drauf das ist
natürlich jetzt noch keine schöne Taste
soll aus Holz sein deswegen habe ich
jetzt hier so eine Tasse konzentriert
wie es gerade sieht dann wiederum wie
immer in die CNC gebaut
so hier kam die raus finde ich schon
super sehr das waren
[Musik]
und dann nehme ich mal jetzt ein
bisschen geschliffen ist
und die kommt dann eben genau auf diesen
Plastik Adapter drauf so und damit ist
die Tasse vorher fertig ihr seht da
fehlt noch Buchstab
[Musik]
jetzt meine Tasten drauf sind steht die
Tastatur zum ersten Mal unter dem Laser
da werden jetzt die ganzen Buchstaben
auf die Tasten drauf gelasert sonst
machen wir Tastatur relativ wenig Sinn
es steht jetzt hier alles auf dem Spiel
mehrere Tage Arbeit wenn da jetzt
irgendwas Falsches und der einfach
komplett drüber lasert ist halt wirklich
jedes einzelne gefunden in diesem Sinne
[Musik]
die F1 Taste ist ein bisschen cursed
aber der Rest ist ziemlich geil so auch
auf die Tasten kann
dann sehen wir auch direkt zehnmal
besser aus
[Musik]
und die letzte mit der Problem
und zwar
ich klebe da jetzt einfach Sprungfedern
rein
[Musik]
und jetzt ist eigentlich nur noch
wichtig funktioniert wenn die Tastatur
moin moin ja Tastatur
drücken und auch das mit den LEDs finde
ich ziemlich cool sogar die Buchstaben
unserer ein bisschen schlecht aber so
dunkel wird gerade selten ich mache mal
ein lang schreibe Test aber wenn ein
bisschen mehr Licht
[Musik]
fertig ganz schön viel Arbeit war das
700 € oder 900 € hätte das Teil
eigentlich gekostet so wenn man es
ungefähr in der Dimension gekauft hätte
ja also es war schon anstrengender
Prozess aber ich glaube 900 Euro ist
noch schmerzhafter aber ich kann
verstehen wieso man so viel verlangt
dafür es ist wirklich sehr viel Arbeit
umso happier bin ich dass die Tastatur
jetzt fertig ist und hier vor uns steht
ich finde es tatsächlich im Hellen noch
schöner als im Dunkeln mit den LEDs ich
glaube die LEDs mache ich auch mal aus
einfach der natürliche Look vom Holz den
Link zu Steuerbord wo er im Schnitt 1.95
€ vom Start zurückkommen könnt findet
ihr in der Videobeschreibung und ich bin
damit raus ich habe jetzt vor Minecraft